I'm saying to her game hey guys this is
what I start playing bendy and the ink
machine parts too
I want to share something with you real
quickly this video I am giving you the
chance to win and easy FMX headset the
very same one that I will be wearing
while playing this game for you
infinitely cooler right my cool level
has just gone up tenfold
okay maybe not but the LED light makes
me feel pretty cool if you would like a
new headset then do stick around to the
end of the video and I will tell you how
you can be into the chance of winning
one of these for yourself you're like
you're like girl look professional so I
look legit no I can never look legit
let's just play the game then leaning
machine chapter selection chapter 2 okay
so yeah carrying on from where we left
off can i massage remember what happened
at the end of the game
oh yeah the little pen to ground thing I
was stuck in there well I guess there's
only one thing to do let's get the axe
and kill see if I can find a way out
okay fine a new exit tip and axe me come
in handy yeah now I'm already way ahead
of you there I might need to change yeah
I need to change the stuff because my
computer rubbish so that's why we came
from right
you can't go back out that way so we
smashed through this door I'm guessing
yes I am a genius
let's get this window open the door how
do i oh okay
he will set us free will you
Oh leave again cuz please get so big do
not remember any of this
you've worked here for quite a while
just a place that you didn't venture the
shadows terrain here sweet blessings
upon me sorry I didn't listen to rest up
but look I want to play it I love little
things like that in game I wish I could
take you with us anyway
huh what you say Amen I said can I get a
name how does that count
okay that was creepy and I cut it short
by playing the freaking banjo so it says
that what that is
I'm gonna get Sony people being like
nervous smell of that is oh well it's
cool
Oh pink what the hell don't speak to him
he's obviously a widow where the hell
did he go he's just moving these Bendis
around do I need it I'm a subpoena for
the sink I'm going to fight him with ink
bill I can't eat it I'm done I'm
obviously not a completionist okay guys
you get power to skate somehow should be
a couple switches in your body then
maybe I can open it we just wrote ever
that we should go I didn't say switch
did you did I miss the switcher probably
do
glad you know switch on you this is such
air but your 2d I can't
switching the coffin nothing's wrong
oh here we go Oh fine Dinks you hiding
oh if I'm keys whack everyday use go be
buying something behind you
indestructible cheer hey there you go
okay now back okay let's go skill skill
fool so another one what does it do
hey I chopped him up early I know you're
back what you're doing alright all of
this getting it I don't trust any of you
oh my bloody balls no this does you want
your even don't even ask me how is it
severe never cause it's having so long
and I feel so frustrated with myself
right now but let's just carry on enjoy
the wonderful game and stop looking for
bloody buttons oh my god
go through the gate just take these keys
come on why are the keys that right Oh
Oh Oh bolt [ __ ] I don't even stop the
hesitate I'm just like yep get me
through tell my light I'm coming right
that like why does that like even come
from where is the source of the light
where's the light sources makes no sense
okay I will just go I will roll with it
the music department ah love this place
yes to find a way to dream again say no
power though why is that some knowledge
of singing wow it's spongebob isn't is
go fear hey Benny I'm gonna play
something for you you ready no not this
don't look at me look at that lovely
nothing Oh
I'll be off your mom the band will this
week oh my god I thought it was like
periodic raise you 10 now
seems like you're all pretty peculiar
yeah okay
oh that was fun glad I did that glad I
came up here that was great thanks Benny
to scaring me
suspend this girlfriend miss angel she
sings and dances
oh yeah cuz i what am i well do you cry
I don't know what I'm doing I can't kill
things upon my name [ __ ]
why are they weird in pinky moses open
this frickin door please I don't know
what I'm doing
[Music]
no no I'm going back where I came from
psych choices hi come at me Oh bull
I don't know what to do I don't know
ducks people's okay that was raised
[Music]
that's break
Oh chill out chill out chill out well I
don't paint oriental so long Oh Brandi
Braman Amanda that's a far far better
did it elected it now's good
hey Ben is gone few to keep you in also
say hey let's play this cello a public
game
okay
oh hey your ups and Timofey I was not
we're going place good for you girl
right let's go check out this new place
yeah so I think I was trying to tell you
that in every episode there's like a new
character introduced so I guess this is
where she comes in this place is not as
friendly down the infirmary and organ
how did you hear that
is there someone in the organ sorry I
can't help you I don't know how to take
people out of organs
do not let Jerry see this why happy sad
disgust angry everything is the same so
you can't tell what what he's thinking
or feeling or anything great that's
great bacon soup oh I didn't realize
those bacon soup others tend to think
what would why am i why am i eating ink
I wasn't faking I loved
- thank you anyway Oh feyza we know it
is keys are cool I know your keys are
I'll go get them all the kind of cartoon
songs are just coming into my head man
where's Lydon right now that's not like
fancy didn't wait well yeah
and we just choose yes my home I'm
totally singing wrong nice and friendly
howdy-do well well there's the pump
switch alright but that's one hell of a
lease blocking the door though really
just company like ethos of it if you can
do them there's gotta be something we
are mr. person sanctuary shall we do of
it
you only know my favorite song
oh let's rhyme Sanjiv yawning clocks run
jump and your piano drum a drum that
goes out once more sing my song
sanctuary thank you for the tips I will
find Wow
Jimmy descry stop it I can't handle
you're not even as scary mmm I need
bacon soup any bacon soup I need to turn
around any bigger soup okay sorry is
that life if they can save my life my
life sauce huh I hate you
I always swing too late okay one we're
doing looking for drums there's
something you gotta do missing something
you feel like you're missing something
that is okay so drown and then falls to
the banjo banjo
and then Piana
and then back to the drum
I am a musician nothing nothing happened
maybe twice is it that is a banjo right
I don't know let's go jump spin jump
Janna jumped a little bump now drop
banjo piano drum okay ready
hey guys Jevon banjo be honest turn to
run banjo piano Jam this is the fact the
second one it's the ring devote banjo
beginning Jim you drunk
banjo Fionna Opel drunk banjo piano
John yes
where is this son
I'm here oh we need to go into the
recording room recording studio oh the
float okay cool he's like oh it makes
everything tense but by Jesus right okay
that was oh [ __ ] both OH both goals both
those little balls of those well though
I'm just looking every day a business
trip over a little bit a little bit
little oh I'm gonna die it's stupid
incompetent like I'm gonna die how am I
still alive if I can complete this game
you can complete this game because I so
odd just a little blood I'm sorry I'm
shaking are going why am I going here
what am i doing
calm down young man
you got this tell me I've got this and
you to support right now okay now I'm
playing a horror game sorry
[Applause]
[Music]
what I thought I drained it oh that's so
embarrassing my house amazing so no I am
good
it's fine take care about me it's nice
oh I see I gotta go into the other room
okay okay okay let's go no kkkk King it
bad Andi this way perfect great great
great pump control what do you say it's
time to believe believe in what mmm
interesting all right sweet now we can
go take the stairs
this is great twenty do I have any more
bacon yeah happy I don't know if it is
health I don't feel better taking it
it's in a game you can be whoever you
want to be and what
there we go now
nice and tight we wouldn't want our
sheep roaming away now slightly it
wasn't all oily a second-deck we
wouldn't I must admit I am honored you
came all the way down here to visit well
you invited me so I'd get some work out
of those two makes what I'm about to do
seem cool or even but the believers must
honor their Savior
I must have him notice me wait you look
familiar to me yeah I was the animator
that please no no for our Lord is
calling to us my little sheep the time
of sacrifice is ahead annachi and then I
will finally be free from this prison
this inky dark abyss I call a body so
increases s-someone listen I can hear
him crawling above a crawl let us begin
said a ritual must be completed ah soon
as you will hear me he will set us free
can I be free cheaply how is this guy
oh oh I mean I'm in a I'm in want to be
a pentagram things again let's just get
okay okay okay where the bloody hell is
max where's my hi where is the hi
I don't know where the axe is gone let's
put the finder but I don't know what it
is right
sighs it sight-size us let me jump OB
let me find my hat
come on it's gonna be like right next to
think oh happy hello
so that was easy even without my axe
[Music]
relax at least keep the sharp end okay
okay which way which way this way this
way I like how the planks is like fun
lead is a bit I'm not complaining this
in ia when I get away from that
situation bacon I know you're in here
come on it's gonna be the girl one right
oh hey it's goofy Boris Boris hey
there's good I enjoyed that oh my gosh I
gotta apologize for my scream it it's
just been a while okay since I played
proper horror games I'm gone back to
being a complete wimp but hey that's why
you clicked on this video right wimpy
girl plays a wimp means someone who gets
scared easily so yeah anyway I hope you
enjoyed that ah thanks for watching me
play of ending in the English Jean I
really hope you found that entertaining
and I can't wait until the next game
adults don't being developed but
hopefully it will be out soon anyway
back to the headset how can you win one
of these well the link will be in the
description below to a tweet that
explains everything
all you have to do is follow me on
twitter follow easy as amex
on twitter and make sure you're
subscribed so the link will be in the
description below and that will give you
all of the information that you need to
get your hands on one of these and a
massive thank you to easy as a mex for
hosting this giveaway i love to give you
guys free stuff who doesn't like free
stuff everyone has free stuff have a
lovely day or evening
ah very I wish I was gay